hello everyone this is me here from
audio science review i have another
product review another one of those
audio file tweaks
uh it's a product called a ground array
uh by a company called cord company uh
it's not cord electronics it's not the
company that makes a cord
dax different company but both situated
in uk it's a low machine aluminum piece
at the end has an rgf45 for ethernet you
plug it into a switcher router and
supposed to reduce the ground noise uh
despite being little this thing costs
eight hundred dollars you can get
different versions of it for different
unused ports in your uh computer uh in
your audio setup uh you can get an rca
one and get usb 1 and even hdmi looks
like and xlr and so forth
on this thing
usually i lead with measurements for
this kind of product but the people who
buy this don't believe in measurements
usually so let's lead with uh listening
test i uh my everyday workstation is a
16 core uh
windows pc that i use for listening and
running all my measurements and testing
is fed by a eight port switch so i had
empty ports to plug this into and i
listened to a range of music while
plugging and unplugging this thing and i
gotta tell you there's absolutely no
difference to my ears whatsoever i
couldn't detect any noise changing
fidelity changing everything sounded
exactly how it should
and it has in the past so no improvement
in in subjective listening tests
but someone
uh watching this video is probably
skeptical of of me thinking that i don't
want to hear the change so i didn't or i
don't have good enough here so let's do
a more conclusive test which is a null
test and
that's done with a program called delta
wave here i play music through the my
rme adi 2 pro which has a dac and adc
built into it so the audio gets
converted to analog and then over xlr
cable gets captured back and i did it
twice once with this plugged into a
switch one
not plugged into a switch and there's
also this you can see that the
difference between the two uh are uh
basically an extremely low noise floor
and we can see the completed null is is
about 110 db or so and uh
the uh what that means is that the noise
floor of the difference is below the
noise floor of the 16-bit audio files
that i've been uh playing in here so
there's absolutely no way this can be
contributing to any difference in the in
the fidelity of two pieces the
soundtrack that
i had recorded now i can let you listen
to these samples i'm going to mute my
microphone in between the idea isn't for
you to hear that two samples and and be
able to tell the difference yourself um
i'm going to keep them very short but i
will then play the null file and
you're welcome to turn up the volume and
and see if you can tell uh what the uh
whether there's
any sound coming out uh audibly
forgetting about the uh spectrum of it
so this is delta wave against uh uh i'm
gonna go ahead and mute myself and
play the first sample
[Music]
double sample number one here's sample
number two
[Music]
and this is the null difference now
you're welcome to turn up the volume and
listen to it
so i'm back um
i don't know if uh because of
compression that's used in youtube but
there's some noise modulation that may
be there in the youtube video i'll
listen to it later on but you're welcome
to get this file through dropbox and
then you'll have the pure digital
version of this that
you can listen to yourself let me go
back to review and here's the dropbox
link and you can click on it and listen
to it directly in dropbox it's able to
play wav files or you can download it
and mess with it with these very
sensitive iems i can boost the levels
about 40 db above my comfortable
listening levels when i'm listening to
this now i absolutely hear silence
there's nothing there in in in there to
contribute to any difference between the
two so as far as the subjective test
is concerned using our ears and using
our brain there's absolutely no
differences made to my setup at all
so but
let's let's be more accurate and use our
measurement and instrumentation because
we can measure much better than our
hearing threshold uh when i first got
into this test i thought the two court
companies were the same so i still have
the core dave dag a 14 000 dac and i
thought i'd use that to
matched it too so there'll be no
complaint about resolution of the device
but turns out there's two different
companies still this is a high-end dac
and if a fourteen thousand dollar that
doesn't show a difference then
hopefully folks uh will agree with the
results so this is accord dave dack
by itself being measured playing a one
kilo stone there's a distortion over
here at -125 db
so 15 db below threshold of hearing when
we have no trouble uh measure or 10 db
below threshold hearing and we have no
trouble measuring that we also have tiny
little spikes in here that around -140
db and we have no trouble measuring
those but uh
let's plug in the uh the ground array
and we see those little ticks are still
here and this distortion has not changed
one bit there's no jitter components in
either case to remove and
you know if you see tiniest variation in
here just because of the run to run
variation output voltage is the same
down to three decimal places and
distortion noise is the same but let's
focus on noise alone
and because that's the company's claim
and with that we measure our dynamic
range the difference between dac playing
nothing to playing the maximum volume
and
we
see that the result with or without this
ground array uh from chord plugged in
it's basically the same there's a bit of
run to run variation one channel of
chord deck is less stable and it does
vary a little bit but the second channel
we see that is accurate to even three
decimal places even though we usually
don't look at
these numbers that accurate
there's a criticism commonly that hey
you know you're only playing a single
tone at one kilohertz maybe there's a
difference with dwell music that's more
towns okay we use 32 tones and we
quickly see that there are
intermodulation distortions coming from
the stack and low frequency ones uh
likely from power supply
but it could also be on the ground of
usb connection to the dac and um but
when i plug in the ground array in there
it makes no difference there's a two
measurements one in blue one in red
they're landing right on top of each
other so there's absolutely no
difference now i want to make sure you
understand what this device is this is
not an electronic filter there's no
circuit that's completed whatsoever all
of these grounding products they
literally just connect to the chassis of
your audio equipment and they come out
with a piece of wire and that piece of
wire is then suspended inside with some
um special material that they filled
this thing with and you can get a boxes
this big with a similar kind of idea
from a company called n-track and there
are other ones that make these grounding
products and the idea is that you can
drain suck
noise out of the ground of your computer
of your audio equipment the ground can
be polluted in audio equipment hence the
reason you should use balanced xlr if
you can but if you're using rca yes that
can become part of the signal whether
it's audible's a different
thing but
if the noise is there there's nothing in
physics that tells you this is able to
do anything with that because electrons
there basically as a noise signal have
no desire to go into something that just
sits in the vapor like this
it wants to complete a circuit and then
electrons will flow if you take a light
bulb connect to one side of a battery
and not the other side light bulb does
not come on right so electrons don't
want to just go to nowhere and they're
happily go between your pieces of
equipment and not care about going to
something that just hanging in the air
with high impedance
so the fundamental principle these
grounding products are able to drain
things from your ground is wrong as
metaphysics as a matter of basics of
electronics that kind of thing does not
work company says this then generates
that the heat converts it to heat that
works with vibration
but
does not work with an electrical signal
like this on top of that in a switch as
i'm using the ports are independent of
each other a network switch and ethernet
switch means i can have port one and two
communicating and the port eight where i
plug this in there has nothing to do
with those two other ports is both
logically and electronically isolated
from this other port that this plug to
plugged into and indeed there are
transformers in there that have an air
gap in there that make sure that the two
circuits grounds are not coupled
together when you use ethernet because
you could have ethernet cable go
hundreds of feet between buildings and
you don't want to have ground loops
causing problems so the whole
fundamental idea of this cannot and does
not work and we've shown with
measurements and listening tests it
doesn't work now the company if you
listen to they have testimonials they've
taken the audio shows plugged this in
and wow everybody said you know fidelity
was improved how can that be you know
are those people delusional no they're
not as i've explained many times
you have a system you play some music
then you say look i'm going to now plug
this in there and all sudden all the
brains become like a microscope focusing
and zooming in trying to hear
differences and when you plug this in
indeed you will hear differences because
your brain starts to filter out all the
a lot of the music tries to take it
apart and focus on smallest detail
whatever you think your idea of high
fidelity is on imaging detail noise
floor the brain becomes more an
instrument and focus on those things so
it hears different than it did when you
were just you know okay there's some
music listening uh music playing
so what and then you plug this in wow it
made a difference the problem is that
later on after you bought this you plug
into your system and you listen sit back
and listen your brain is no longer doing
that kind of parting of the waves and
doing that in analysis is able to now
just relax and listen and this device
will no longer have that false
impression on you and will do nothing if
you disagree with me
turn on your cell phone video have a
loved one switch this or not switch it
10 out of 10 times and see if you can
get eight or nine times out of ten
accurately identify what is plugged in
or not we need the video so we can see
if you could see what's going on we need
some documentation we need to
know how the whole thing was set up yeah
you know where the sequence is random
please don't come back so i plugged and
unplugged it blind and i could tell
difference one time doesn't mean
anything twice doesn't mean anything
three times doesn't mean anything i've
done these tests where four or five
times i was right and then 50 times i
was wrong after that so
you know you can get like a few times in
a row just like flipping of a coin but
you need to run it enough times so that
uh we know that it's a statistically
reliable thing uh unfortunately you know
if it doesn't work you're out eight
hundred dollars so
please don't spend your money on this
kind of thing
okay see you in a future video bye bye